welcome back i now want to play a little
bit of devil's advocate with myself you
know i made this argument where i show
that for the exact identical house if
these are the numbers i mean you'd have
to work it out based on your market and
what the numbers are at the time but if
this has the comparable rent for a
million dollar house i showed you that
for the million dollar house you're
burning forty thousand dollars a year
it's this is not money that is going to
build equity this is not money that's
going to the principle of your house
this is money that is going out of your
pocket and you'll never see again in a
way and actually not in a way in reality
you can view this forty thousand dollars
as rent on the money that you borrowed
interest is nothing but rent so when you
have an asset
if the asset is cash the rent on it is
interest if the asset is a house the
rent on it is your monthly rent payment
so when you think of it this way when
people say home ownership they really
aren't home owners yet you're not a
homeowner until you
don't have debt you are a you are a
money a money renter so your choice is
either to be a money renter here or to
be a house renter here and i show that
you are burning almost double the money
but then there's there's there's the
argument of well well there there are
advantages still to buying this house
and what are they
well one example is in this situation if
i did get a fixed rate mortgage and we
learned you know when you look at all
those adjustable rate mortgages we know
that a lot of people didn't but if i
have a fixed rate mortgage i know what
my payment is for the foreseeable future
for the next 30 years while my landlord
in this case in the rental they could
keep raising my rent so
this this might look good right now but
what if my landlord raised the rent to i
don't know 3500 a month
well then out of your pocket 0.5 times
12.
you'd be spending 42 000 a year and then
of course you get the interest from the
the money that you put in the bank plus
10.
oh minus 10 actually no minus
sorry
so in that case if the rent goes up then
out of your pocket is 32 000 every year
right or what if the interest that you
get on your cash in the bank goes down
then this 10 000 will become lower but
as we can see the rent would have to go
up a lot to make up for 41 to to make
this a break even situation let's figure
out how much it would have to go up
so
in order for your net in this first
scenario in order for your net outflow
to be 41
hundred
you're
assuming you're getting ten thousand
from the money in the bank your rent
would have to be fifty one thousand five
hundred so it's fifty one five hundred
right because you're getting ten
thousand from the bank
and so divided by twelve
your rent would have to be forty three
hundred dollars
your rent would have to be forty three
hundred dollars
in this situation
to make this a break even proposition
and you can view it i mean this is
another way to view it if i were to buy
the house and if i were to move how much
would i have to rent this house out for
in order to
not be losing money every month well i
would have to rent it out for 4 300 a
month even though maybe the market rents
are only at three thousand
and then well there's there's another
devil's uh uh advocate argument and
that's well housing has and this was
something that you heard a lot about
three years ago and a lot of these
people aren't talking as much now but
that they would say housing has never
housing has done nothing but gone up and
i will build equity just from housing
appreciation so how much does my house
have to appreciate every year
well to make up this difference
41
41
500
minus
26
so to make up that 15 500 difference
every year
every year this is fifteen thousand five
hundred favorable
my house would have to appreciate by a
comparable amount right
so how much appreciation is that on my
house
well that's a million dollar house right
so fifteen thousand five hundred
dollars appreciation on a million dollar
house so
i'm doing everything in thousands so a
thousand thousands a million
so that's only one point five percent
appreciation
so if my house appreciates by one point
five percent
that's it one point five percent if my
house just appreciates by one point five
percent i'm going to make up this
fifteen thousand five hundred and so it
is worth it for me it is worth it for me
to blow this money by having kind of an
increased uh by renting the money for
more than i would have to pay to rent
the house
and that might sound like a very
reasonable proposition that the house
will appreciate by 1.5 percent from from
2001 to 2005 2006 houses were
appreciating like 10 15 a year so it
seemed and a real estate agent would
often do this very math with you and say
well you're definitely going to get 1.5
in fact you're probably going to get 10
appreciation and you're going to make
much more than this but think about what
in in the presentation of the balance
sheet and leverage
what happens if housing prices go down
by 1.5 percent what happens if it's
minus 1.5 percent
well then you're you're gonna you're
going to spend this much to rent the
money right
and you're not going to gain this much
you're going to lose this much every
year and so the proposition becomes even
worse so this is a big deal now that you
know i think on a nationwide basis a lot
of the housing indices show that housing
prices have gone down i think by six
percent that's what the case-shiller
index says
um six percent's a lot especially like a
million dollar house that's 60 000 a
year that's just evaporating that's
wealth that someone thought they had
that's just disappearing out of their
equity so
this this rationale of paying more to
rent the money for a house then to rent
the house
is justified if housing prices go up it
becomes 10 times worse when housing
prices are flat or god forbid if housing
prices actually go down and now we see
that housing prices actually go down
in the last couple years especially in
the areas where like the bay area or
florida or california especially you
know southern california where this is
happening and you know what back even
two three years ago when people used to
make this argument
people used to make the argument well
you know my house just has to go up one
or two percent and i'm going to make up
the difference i'd say well why is your
house going to go up one or two percent
is it because
i mean there has to be some reason why
next year someone's willing to pay two
percent more for that house
is it because rents are going up two
percent a year so the income stream is
going to be two percent higher and
actually in the bay area from 2001 to
2000 and roughly three rents were going
down and there were actually people
moving out all the tech workers were
getting laid off you had a lot of
programming jobs being outsourced to
india and wherever else so you had this
whole situation where the population was
actually decreasing demand for housing
was going down but
but for some reason housing prices were
going up so people said well they've
been going up for the last five years so
they'll continue and they've never gone
down et cetera et cetera but it didn't
make an economic argument and i'll show
in a future video that the only reason
why housing prices did go up is that it
just became easier and easier and easier
to buy a house financing got
the standards that banks used that for
giving out a loan became lower and lower
and lower they're actually examples in
in southern california and in you know
in san jose and some of the suburbs
where you know people who had incomes of
30 or 40 000 a year the bank actually
gave them a million dollar loan to buy a
million dollar house based on stated
income these there's there's things
called stated income loans where you
just tell the bank what you earn you
don't have to prove it to them and so
every year that went by just became
easier and easier and easier more and
more people just thought that housing
always appreciates so that's why they
want to pay more and more to essentially
rent the money for a house
and just became a self-fulfilling
prophecy but as we see on the way down
it works completely against you so in a
situation where we are now where
nationwide housing prices are actually
declining and actually they will decline
until this rent versus buy equation
starts to make a little bit more sense
it it really hurts the home buyer and
what's even worse and this is kind of
adding insult to injury is that this
this guy once you know if i bought this
house and all of a sudden i lose my job
and i can't pay the house back i might
lose my entire 250 000 down payment
because maybe i can't sell the house or
the house is selling for less
or maybe i want to move and just there's
no one out there who can buy a house
because
the the banks all of a sudden got smart
again and realized that they should
become more serious in terms of who they
give money to and so i'm stuck holding
this house and my flexibility in terms
of where i can move is limited actually
a friend of mine was telling me that
they've actually done studies and
there's a correlation between
unemployment and home ownership because
when you own a home
you have less flexibility in looking for
a job if i have a house in san jose but
there's a job in la i might not be able
to take that job because i can't sell my
house or i might not even want to look
for a job in la while the renter of
course i could just you know my lease
ends and i leave
so you know this is just a rough sense
of the rent versus buy and i know i get
very impassioned about this but that's
just because i've i explained this a lot
and when i'm at parties you know and i
start talking about the calculations
people's eyes closed over but i made
this video now and i'll just tell tell
people to watch it
see you in the next video